so rain in the valley this time of year
means snow up in the mountains Mary Jane
beliesza went to Lee Canyon to see how
they're preparing for ski season
[Music]
it's a busy day for our nearby ski
resorts like Lee Canyon with this winter
storm marketing director Jim Seeley says
there's plenty of work to do as they
prepare for the season including
prepping the facilities the equipment
and hiring seasonal staff just by
looking at the ground and you know just
me eyeballing it maybe we've received
around one inch less than two inches
since this morning or so but looking at
the forecast it looks like this
afternoon mid afternoon we can we can
start to see a couple inches per hour
that's going to happen and then you know
by the end of the snowfall you know
possibly around 20 21 inches or so uh
you know as as the storm totals so we're
really excited with rain wind and high
elevation snow in the forecast
enthusiasts hope this will kick off the
start to an early season to hit the
slopes we'd like to see a little bit
more snow coming in December but
unfortunately you know we don't get that
Brandon Davis has been skiing since 2019
and take five to ten trips with his
family during the winter season
hopefully we'll get more snow in the
most the December and we'll be able to
go a lot more but typically seems that
you know January through March are going
to be your ideal months ham is Rahi
agrees he's an avid snowboarder and
tries to get a few runs in any chance he
gets having a family we have to plan
around a lot of schedules and what we
like to do is get a couple families or
three families together and make sure we
get at least two trips in for the season
Seeley says early December is their
target date to open as they hope for
more snowfall and colder temperatures to
make snow a couple feet of snow actually
surprisingly isn't enough to open a skew
area so but you know again there's a lot
of factors involved with moisture
content and whatnot
um and if it's going to get warm again
or not at Lee Canyon Mary June bellissa
8 News Now